une ville qui se veut accueillante
malgré ses fortifications
impressionnants ces jours ci c'est malo
est loin d'être envahi peu de touristes
dans la ville d'où jacques cartier a
pris la mer pour découvrir le canada se
dévide n est forcé de rester au port la
crise a gelé ses affaires
tout a été annulé les mariages ont été
annulés les anniversaires les sorties en
mer ont été annulés donc tout est annulé
à quai mais pas inactif depuis quelques
jours l'équipage offre des visites de ce
trois mâts baptisé le français est-ce
qu'il va y avoir du monde parce que il
est 10h15 voilà donc là on ouvre bon
mais bon on va voir désespoir de maigres
revenus à peine de quoi rester à flot
ont fait un test anti ça marche bien là
on va persévérer
si ça marche pas on ira à la pêche sur
la terre ferme
l'ambiance est davantage hygiénique
qu'estivale d'ordinaire les rues de la
vieille ville devrait être beaucoup plus
achalandée un tiers de l'économie de
saint malo dépend de ce que dépensent
les touristes ici c'est le problème
on ne sait toujours pas combien pourront
se rendre jusque dans la vieille ville
jusqu'à nouvel ordre la majorité des
français ne peuvent venir jusqu'ici
les déplacements sont limités 100 km du
domicile et les voyages entre pays
demeure compliquée restaurateurs et
hôteliers s'en inquiète et sans plainte
au maire c'est absolument dramatique
alors évidemment la pression est énorme
et c'est logique de leur part et nous on
est là pour essayer de trouver ce juste
équilibre pour ouvrir montrer qu'on
existe qu'on sera présent
puis en même temps ne pas prendre de
risque on en saura plus d'ici quelques
jours
dans ce centre de villégiature aux
abords de saint malo on fait tout pour
sauver la saison estivale ce que vous
avez procéder à des remboursements
ces temps ci on propose beaucoup de
retard les reports les gens acceptent et
sont ravis
ces jours ci le vaste domaine a plutôt
des airs de village fantôme
ici la majorité des vacanciers viennent
d'ailleurs en europe
une clientèle qui pourrait bien ne pas
venir en france cette année et vous
voyez on n'a même pas pris la peine de
nettoyer nos piscines par cet été le
domaine certains accueillir moitié moins
de vacances si on va quand même faire
une saison tout petit mais saison un peu
particulière parce qu'on ne sera pas
renforcée des trois cents saisonniers
habituels
tous ces saisonniers qui vont pas avoir
de travail d'été nous plus d'autres plus
d'autres plus d'autres ça tout l'air
leur semblait une crise économique ça ou
domaine on regarde cette immense dôme
neuf comme une sorte de bouée de
sauvetage
il a coûté très cher mais pourrait bien
permettre de recevoir des clients au
delà de la saison estivale alors
normalement ici on entendait les cris
d'enfants dans les toboggans là bas dans
les vagues
en attendant le retour des visiteurs il
n'y a presque personne
pour profiter de ce petit coin de
paradis